is Richard Layman and he loved physics
between 1918 and 1988 he developed
quantum mechanics won the Nobel Prize
and was the best known scientist in the
world
what's less well known about him however
is despite his obvious intellect and
passion and drive there were times where
in his own words he said physics disgust
me a little bit now but I used to really
enjoy doing it and even the likes of
Richard Freeman can become unmotivated
about their one true passion in life
what hope do people like me have to stay
motivated and want to consistently do
things when I'm not even 100 sure
they're My One True passion or the thing
that I continuously want to do somewhat
controversially on this channel I've
mentioned in the past that I Rely mostly
on my motivation in order to get things
done so today I've compiled the things
that people like Richard Clayman
evidence-based science and my own
personal experience have taught me about
the little mistakes that I've
accidentally been doing in the past that
end up lowering my motivation and make
it in the long term harder for me to do
things and enjoy doing them so here's
how to stay motivated passionate and
driven about the things that we want
let's get straight into it now I'm going
to jump straightened with the
controversial mistakes but I'm just
going to try and explain this properly
basically the first mistake that I think
used to trash my motivation was that I
rewarded myself for doing things and I
think the solution to this is to never
give myself rewards for doing activities
please please let me explain this is
based both on a lot of kind of
evidence-based studies but also my own
personal experience but basically what I
used to do in the past is that for
example throughout the year if I knew
that I needed a phone upgrade if I
needed a new pair of shoes or a new coat
or to go on a holiday or to do something
nice for myself what I would do is that
I would kind of schedule these in either
as a birthday gift or as a Christmas
gift or for example after an exam I'm
going to be allowed to buy this book
that I really really wanted or I'm going
to upgrade my phone if I finish this
project or if I finally start this
YouTube channel now I no longer do this
because I find that in the long term
this ends up destroying my intrinsic
motivation for getting those tasks done
so I'm going to start with the studies
themselves but there's basically a huge
body of evidence that shows that when
children are rewarded for doing certain
things they end up enjoying those tasks
a lot less and stopping them sooner in
one particular study two groups of
children were made to perform puzzles
and only half of those children so one
group were given rewards for doing the
puzzle these are the children that ended
up enjoying the puzzles less and stopped
doing them sooner than the other group
that were never rewarded and just meant
to do the thing now this might sound
like forced action but the way that
these studies interpret this and the way
that I see it too is that when I am not
giving myself an external reward for a
specific action I end up being much more
likely trying to find intrinsic pleasure
in doing the task itself and I also find
this in my own childhood where there are
activities for which I was not given any
specific reward for completing like
painting or reading and these are
activities that I still very much enjoy
as an adult because of the intrinsic
pleasure in the activity itself rather
than other things that I was kind of
encouraged or motivated or stimulated to
do externally I think I really
internalize this parental role where I
used to have a parent in the past tell
me to do something and then reward me or
only allow me to play computer games for
example when I am done doing this task
and I think I never learned to actually
trust myself and to do things because I
wanted to do them or when I wanted to do
them without This Promise of a reward so
I kind of internalized this parent and
always in the past I used to put Rewards
or put things in the end of doing tasks
because I in my mind thought I would
never do them if I didn't do this and
also that I would be more encouraged to
do things this in my personal experience
just doesn't work another personal
reason if you are similar to me where
this reward for an activity ruins my
motivation is because rewards spaced in
time just don't work for me if I promise
myself that I'm going to give myself a
gift in a month that doesn't mean that
I'm going to look forward to it more it
just means that I am going to look
forward to it less and not even want the
gift I'm very much an immediate reward
kind of person I can be very impatient
so spacing out my rewards just makes me
frustrated in the meantime rather than
looking forward to Something in the
future I know this would be different if
you're not an impatient person so this
might not work for you but I think this
realization also made me think that
actually there's no point in waiting for
things and I can get them as soon as I
want them so if you also feel that to
some extent you treat yourself like a
child or you mistrust what you would
naturally want to do maybe that's
because you've never naturally let
yourself do the things that you want
motivation itself is an intrinsic drive
or desire and if you're always cutting
it off by stopping yourself doing things
by redirecting your attention by trying
to redirect your motivation then you
never trust that you can do things
yourself and you never Flex or exercise
this muscle so I would really really
recommend just giving yourself rewards
which can be very very small things
whenever you want them upgrading your
phone when you need it buying something
new when you need it watching the movie
when you want to rather than forcing
yourself to do it as soon as you're done
with an activity which might lead you
you to resent the activity itself in the
long term and to find that you are
actually never building motivation for
doing tasks but you're just trying to
negotiate with yourself for the rest of
your life with bigger and unsustainable
Rewards or rewards for even basic things
in order to get things done so this is
what I would recommend the second way
that damages my motivation seems to
perhaps on the surface contradict the
first one but there's one very very
subtle and very important difference
that I want to get across the second
thing is under paying myself for tasks
that I am doing very importantly this
doesn't mean an extra gift or reward at
the end of the task but this is the
specific payment or payoff either
emotional or physical for getting
something done basically this is
connected to the Richard feyman story so
the thing I first mentioned was that
even though feyman absolutely loved
physics he ended up resenting it when
you had to give some lectures on
Aeronautics in Buffalo and in his book
sure you're joking Mr feyman which is an
absolute excellent read would strongly
recommend it actually I'm going to check
if there is a short form kind of summary
that I would link below if you would
like to see it there basically what
happened to Feynman was that he was
given extra money to travel to this town
and give a physics lecture every weekend
and he would go there he would give the
lecture he would stay the weekend and he
would come back and he ended up being
completely burnt out and hating the
whole experience and his realization at
some point was that he had a very poor
person mentality and all the extra money
that he was given for this inconvenience
he was just saving because he'd come
from a poor background and he wasn't
used to spending lots of luxuries on
himself but his realization was that he
was being paid this extra money to do a
painful experience of traveling and
being away from home and so he decided
that he was going to spend all the extra
bits of the money in order to enjoy
himself there and suddenly The
Experience became fun now if you're
healthy this might sound completely
obvious but in my case I've in the past
been the sort of person who expects
myself to perform the same every single
day for example I'm due to work through
three hours on a project if it's a
Monday if it's a Sunday if I had a
terrible day if I'd just been crying if
a friend just opened up with something
tragic to me I expect myself to be able
to perform the same every single time
and I never realized that sometimes I'm
working overnight or I need extra pay in
the same way that for example if you do
a night shift as a dog show you get paid
extra money if you don't end up kind of
giving yourself a longer break or if you
don't end up spending a bit more money
on yourself you're going to end up
resenting the task because it was done
at a ridiculous expectation so when I'm
working an unpaid job which is basically
studying and everything that I need to
do with myself I will often ask myself
if I'm doing overtime hours if I'm
working extra shift if I'm working on a
sick day if I'm working when I'm unwell
or sad or going through a difficult time
I will realize that this is kind of
overtime and for that reason I deserve
later perhaps a longer break or I
deserve a small reward something like
guessing my favorite juice at the shops
or just get getting my favorite lunch
for example and very small things like
this aren't necessarily huge gifts or
rewards but they're the fair pay for the
work that I have done and kind of
realizing that I should not expect
myself to perform the same in every
single case and some jobs just require
extra pay and using that pay on myself
that means that I can maintain my
motivation for a longer period just like
Feynman and not end up burnt out and
resenting what I'm doing because I'm
working in a ridiculous State now the
third way that I can burn through my
motivation is timing and this is
something that I am very interested in
and super passionate about basically my
friends joke that I live in another
space-time because I have in general a
very poor concept of what time is my
estimations of five minutes or 30
minutes or a day or an hour are just
absolutely ridiculous but that is beyond
the point I think the reason that I can
stay more motivated than others
sometimes for things has to do with my
very poor concept of time because not
actually I don't tend to think of
activities in terms of how long they
take but I think of them as an activity
itself and very interesting I was
reading a book called 4 000 weeks where
it was explaining how people in the past
for example in the village they never
would think of time as being one hour or
two hours they would describe the time
it took things in terms of activities it
took medieval people for example would
say that a task took a miser rare while
I think that's how it's pronounced which
is approximately the time that I took to
recite Psalm 50 or for example they said
there would be back in the time that it
took to bake bread so this is how they
would conceptualize things and I think
in the present day of course because we
are very often paid by ours or we're
expected to do things in hours when it
comes to self-work I will also tell
myself I'm going to do an hour's worth
of studying or revision and this just
works very very badly for me mostly
because I feel that I am stuck in a
chair having to do something for let's
say an hour and if I'm doing studying
for example in the beginning I'm kind of
going to be bored art I know I can't do
anything else because I forced myself to
do it and I will just do a pitiful
amount of work in the end try to make it
through the hour maybe at some point
become motivated then the hour's done
I'm excited I can leave and this whole
activity has just been miserable
unmotivated and just completely
pointless most of the time now what I do
is I break tasks into this medieval way
of thinking where I go oh I'm going to
revise the cardiac valves and this is
the task that I'm going to do and I know
that I'm happy just doing this in a
whole day for example so even if it
takes me five minutes or five hours very
often I'm just happy doing it because
I'm doing a task so if you also find
that being forced to do work leads to
very low amounts of motivation on your
end perhaps just this subtle shift of
thinking that you're going to complete a
task and let that take however long it
must put a timer on if you must stop and
start something else so if you're
expected to be somewhere but I wouldn't
kind of do arbitrary work which is why
also I don't use the Pomodoro method and
I have a whole video on why I hate it
but this is the exact same reason I
don't like doing forced work based on
time but I like doing specific tasks
based on what I want to learn or what I
want to accomplish which I find to be
much more fun have much higher levels of
motivation and also it's almost like the
difference between getting paid for a
task and getting paid per hour people
are notorious saying that when people
are paid per hour they just do very
unmotivated and unproductive work but
when people are paid to do a specific
task they're in and out of your house
fixing your boiler in 15 minutes because
that's just the time that it needs to
get something done so I also pay Myself
by the task that I do rather than buy
the hour and this ends up ending oh my
God that sounded very weird
um rewarding myself for the task but
I've been rewarding Myself by the hour
and getting something done anyway moving
on swiftly now the next mistake that I
used to make about my motivation is what
I call digging into the trowel and this
is again a reference to physics so you
can blame Richard feyman for this but
basically I don't see my motivation for
tasks to be separate from My overall
life motivation and everything else that
is happening in my life so basically the
way that I picture it is that everything
that is happening for example my
University my body image my
relationships my friendships my
connections with my family the tasks
that I'm doing my job my University my
exams all of these have some sort of
sine wave pattern where I'm happy and
I'm sad and I'm happy and I'm sad and
this is just natural these different
sine waves will have different sort of
frequencies and different sort of
wavelengths but basically the overall
states that I am in my life is kind of a
combination and a summary of all of
these waves and very often this might be
baseline or slightly above Baseline when
I'm lucky but there will be times just
because of pure
unfortunate circumstances that a lot of
these waves a lot of the trials of these
waves were super important pose and
leave to this very deep pit of despair
and this is where sometimes for no
reason I don't know why I'm just
miserable I'm just really really sad and
that might be because for whatever
reason for a few hours or a few days
everything in my life might just not be
going too well or might be a bit wobbly
and when I am in this case I realize
that my overall motivation which is kind
of the sum of all of these waves my mood
and motivation tend to be kind of very
similar and very close to one another is
in the pits of hell it says nowhere it's
gone it's trashed and I think if then
I'm trying to force myself to do
something especially if this is
something arbitrary I am digging into
the trial deeper and I'm just digging
myself deeper into a hole where I am
kind of stealing from future motivation
and I'm forcing myself to do something
it's miserable it's sad I'm going to
prolong this pain and not get out of it
faster so so basically what I tend to do
at the moment and it might sound very
wishy-washy but when I can't afford to
and this is with self different tasks I
before I do something or before I sit
down to do something or plan to do
something I just take a second to check
in on how I feel and where these waves
lie and am I intrinsically motivated and
am I intrinsically happy and sometimes
especially if I have a very very big
task to do for example kind of scripting
conceptualizing filming editing after
editing and posting videos is a huge
huge task and to do this I get a lot
more out of just spending 10 minutes or
five minutes calling a friend or just
sitting down with myself and writing why
I'm feeling bad or why I'm not feeling
well rather than trying to push through
and dig myself deeper into that trial
and do unmotivated work which will just
prolong my misery and make me sadder
especially because I haven't invested in
making myself feel better and my work is
probably going to be mediocre so
whenever I can't afford it I tend to
measure my levels of mood try to invest
in those rather than digging and pushing
into my motivation further and further
and also realizing that even though my
overall levels of motivation or mood
might be quite low there's always going
to be a wave in there somewhere and that
may wave might just be my love for art
or my love for music which is usually
very very high all the time and I can
kind of rely on those things and pick
out those waves themselves and do
something enjoyable in order to invest
in my motivation rather than kind of
ignoring this whole thing and pretending
or forcing myself to work just no matter
what at every single case which I find
to be very very unsustainable lastly I
want to give the biggest acts to the
most appropriate sponsor ever for this
video which are brilliant Bridget is
both a mobile app and an online platform
that plays a huge role in maintaining
fueling and replenishing my motivation
for studying Sciences through doing
different exercises you can re-teach
yourself what learning should be like as
an adult and also you can re-energize
and give yourself the motivation and the
confidence in reapproaching things such
as mathematics and logic which have so
many far reaching applications in our
own personal lives love the way that
brilliant me almost relive The Sciences
and learning in the way that I wish it
could have been done to me in the past
in school but also mathematics and logic
I would really really recommend if you
are an adult in any sort of stem subject
or doing any sort of Science and also
for fun I do like to do the physics but
admittedly that has less applications in
my professional and academic life so if
you also want to check brilliant out and
see what I Rave about quite a lot on
this channel there will be a link in my
description which will give you I think
20 off or just the chance to kind of
check it out and have a little trial and
play around with the exercises and see
what you can teach yourself and how you
can re-motivate yourself to learn things
in general but on that note thank you so
much for spending this time with me if
you did I hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day be kind yourself and others
and don't believe everything you think
thanks bye